hey it's evan i'm here at the toronto
airport i'm about to get on a flight i'm
heading for barcelona and i got a
message from somebody on a youtube
viewer and he wrote in to say hey this
is the first time i've ever left a
comment on your video i've kind of been
stalking you been watching everything
you've done since the first time i left
the comment and i thanked him
and for all of you guys who watch these
videos whether it be mine or other
people leave a comment you know most of
these people creating these videos just
like myself like we're not getting paid
to do this we do this because we love
doing it i do these videos because i
love helping entrepreneurs i want to see
you be successful i believe in you guys
i'm trying to answer your questions give
you some help
and really what fuels me is seeing your
comments come in
when people write in to say hey that was
great information you've changed my life
or you've made my day that makes me feel
good that makes you want to get up and
do another video and keep on working
keep on hustling
so if you are a fan of this channel
you're a fan of any channel support the
people leave a comment give it a thumbs
up just let them know you like the video
without even you know leaving a comment
on it like you don't have to share your
opinion you don't have to ask a question
just say
you know what this video was great i
loved it thank you or give a smiley face
anything just leave something man it
makes the people who create it
feel good about themselves and want to
keep doing it and
especially if the person's just starting
up you know like i get a ton of comments
i still love seeing them i'm not saying
don't leave comments on mine
leave comments man it makes me feel good
but for people who are just starting up
who don't have a lot of comments if you
see a video that they make support them
and give them some feedback give them
some
some positive vibe because that one
comment
your comment could make the difference
between them staying in business or not
you know what keeps me motivated every
day is watching the new comments come in
and be harder for me if i didn't have
those coming in every day so if you like
something you see a video that you like
leave a comment just let that person
know that you love what they're doing
and keep it up
thanks guys i'm about to hop this flight
you like this video give it a thumbs up
and hey you know what leave a comment
okay see you guys soon cheers
you